كما نفى موسى فكري رئيس مفوضيه الاتحاد
الافريقي قيام المفوضيه بتقديم دعوه
لاسرائيل لحضور القمه الافريقيه مضيفا في
رده على سؤال لمراسل الجزيره خلال المؤتمر
الصحفي الختامى للقمه الافريقيه ان مساله
حضور الوفد الاسرائيلي قيد التحقيق الامن
وان الوضع القانوني بشان قبول اسرائيل
كعضو مراقب بالاتحاد معلق لحين بث لجنه
السبعه التي شكلت العام الماضي في ذلك
ناقشنا العمل الماضي وضع اسرائيل كمراقب
في الاتحاد الافريقي وبعد هذه النقاشات
المختلفه قرر المؤتمر تشكيل لجنه من رؤساء
الدول للبث في هذه المساله وهذا يعني ان
الوضع القانوني معلق حتى تفصل فيه هذه
اللجنه وبالتالي لم ندعو مسؤولين رسميين
اسرائيليين الى قمتنا لاحظنا وجود شخصيه
دخلت القاعه ببطاقه دخول وطالبناها
بمغادره المكان ونحن نقوم بالتحقيقات
الضروريه لانها شخصيه لا تقيم هنا وجاءت
من اسرائيل ولا يمكن ان يصل احد الى هنا
الا بدعوه من رئيس مفوضيه الاتحاد
الافريقي ونحن لم ندعو اي مسؤول ولا حظنا
ما حدث وسنقوم بالتحقيق لتحديد المسؤوليات